maybe that's the difference between
you
and me
I've always known
ever since I was little
no one was coming to save me any
worshiping has died she was 45 years old
the actress best known for 24 Star Trek
Picard and the rookie died after a
battle with cancer her publicist
confirmed the sad news to E.T Annie's
husband Stephen Full reflected on his
family's loss in a statement to deadline
writing quote there is a cavernous hole
in the soul of this family today but she
left us the tools to fill it she found
Wonder in the simplest moment she didn't
require music to dance she taught us not
to wait for adventure to find you go
find him
following news of her death Annie's
receiving an outpour of support from
Hollywood her Star Trek co-stars Alison
Pill and Jerry Ryan shared sweet
messages with Allison writing she was
funny and wonderful and kind and will be
so missed and Jerry sharing my heart
breaks for her beautiful family so it's
really been fun Annie's former the
rookie co-star ever caradine started a
GoFundMe to support Annie's grieving
family ma'am if you're trying to shock
me in for disappointment
challenge
Paul Wesley who worked with Annie on The
Vampire Diaries shared the fundraiser
adding she was a wonderful and talented
person
so much has already been lost you
haven't lost me
Annie survived by husband Stephen and
their three children Freddie Ozzie and
Archie
as a mother is it having your children
on set it's really wonderful because
it's just nice to come back and get a
little a little kissy shmoopy break
[Music]